what's your number to have an x-rated
only fans account like a cost yeah
what's no I never never there's no cost
there's no price
the amount you can make with doing the
PG content that's just fine with me have
you thought about the amount you could
make okay let's let's do this let's do
this let's do this right now million
dollars in your bank account if you do
the an x-rated post yes or no okay five
million will you just show your test for
a million dollars no I don't think so
not at this age maybe if I was like if I
had like a million kids and I needed to
like I was like dying but like I don't
need it right now since I love like this
job so much I don't think so but if I
didn't have a job and that's all I had
like if bars like you're fired you can
never get a job gonna be like fine okay
you know what I mean so no number yeah
you'd have to be in the scarcity
mentality or I'd have to like take this
sex worker route to want to do that you
need to put food on the table yeah yeah
and then you're gonna go big yeah what
about you no number oh I'm not a very
high number yeah
that's always been my thing though I'm
like yeah it's not that like